Colson,
get back to base.
This is a level seven.
As of right now,
we are at war.
We do.
One of the things you got to love about
just weeding is that he rarely lets a
detail go to waste.
My favorite example is what you just saw
from the first avengers movie when he
uses the film title card literally as an
answer to a question that's been posed
by a character on screen.
It's a great little joke because it sets
the tone for the whole movie by drawing
attention to the films.
Packaging Wieden is letting us know that
he knows that this is just a movie,
that it's not going to take itself too
seriously and that there are going to be
jokes that matters.
Playing Gallagher,
he does a similar thing at the end of
avengers to using a creative cut that
literally plants a word in your head.
Fleet.
We're all thinking of the same word.
No.
Now maybe
it's a small thing,
but the way art is packaged has always
fascinated me because packaging like
this is just another thing that the
artists has to choose it all to be a
creative decision,
like all the creative decisions that
went into the work itself.
Of course,
when you're dealing with big properties
and millions of dollars,
artists don't always or even usually get
to choose what a film or a book title is
going to be.
The book cover or the movie poster is
often designed with commercial
incentives in mind,
but that's not the case for all art
forms or even all forms of packaging.
We didn't obviously had to name his film
the Avengers,
but he found an interesting way to work
that title into the film.
Similarly,
in the 2006 James Bond Movie Casino
Royale director Martin Campbell and the
bond team,
we're looking to reboot the franchise
for a post Austin powers.
Posts can't be era to make it more
gritty and in line with the best action
films of the time.
Obviously they had to include the iconic
gunbarrel sequence,
but by foregoing the normal.dot
dot gunbarrel,
instead working it into the story,
they broadcast the message that this
bond is a different beast altogether.
My interest in this kind of packaging,
I think springs from epigraphs.
Those quotes you see at the beginning of
books,
I use graphs to signal that the reader
should look in this direction while
reading that they should keep certain
things in mind pass.
That's a favorite writer of mine,
m John Harrison,
who I think hits the point exactly
epigraphs indeed all the trappings that
exist in and around a work of art are in
some way a part of it.
Their instructions or simply suggestions
on how to receive the project in
question.
This is a good example from Terentino's
grindhouse feature death proof,
which couches the story in the look and
feel of exploitation genre movies of the
19 seventies all the way down to the
grainy film stock and the fake trailers
for similarly styled b movies.
These kinds of touches,
they're not directly part of the
self paint.
The immediate space around the movie
with a kind of aura that sets the mood.
Of course there are plenty of examples
of beautiful title sequences going back
through the history of film.
The king of them all is Saul Bass,
the designer behind everything from
psycho and Vertigo to Goodfellas and
casino,
and here's how bass use his job.
I had
time.
That's the audience involvement with a
film should really begin with the very
first frame seemed to be a real
opportunity to use titles in a new way,
actually create a climate for the story
that was about to unfold.
That's his philosophy of establishing
the film is the climate lives on.
Even if extended title sequences are
becoming a little less common.
Actually,
I've been noticing a lot of these title
sequences moving to the end of films.
The closing credits of Blue Valentine,
for example,
features,
quick firework,
glimpses of the relationship that just
ended with the film.
I remember watching these credits in the
theater and being completely transfixed
as they send your mind back across the
story,
making the heartbreak of the ending even
more poignant and on the complete other
side of the spectrum,
the closing credit sequence of 22 jump
street is a brilliant send up of
Hollywood's franchise mentality of
endless sequels.
It's maybe the first time I've ever seen
a credit sequence that is even funnier
than and already hilarious movie.
One of the examples I love most is the
title sequence from Francoise Truffaut's
adaptation of Fahrenheit 4:51,
a story about a society that doesn't
allow it to citizens to read books,
so to banish words from the viewer's
mind.
Truffaut has the opening titles read
aloud.
Instead,
I'm a novel by Ray Bradbury music by
comment back to a photography.
Nicholas Roeg.
Not every film or every piece of art
needs to pay so much attention to the
packaging that surrounds it,
but I love something like this because
it actually adds to the story.
The same could be said for the title
sequence of the wire,
which entwines fragments of all the
narrative perspectives of the show and
even some footage from the episodes
themselves and puts them on an equal
footing reinforcing creator David
Simon's maxim that the wire is not about
Jim McNulty or Avon Barksdale or crime
or punishment or drugs or violence.
It's about the city.
These titles I think do a little more
than echo the theme.
They helped to develop it.
All artists are trying in some way to
get their intentions across to an
audience even if that intention is to
make the packaging around their work as
minimal as possible.
A number of painters don't title their
canvases example or simply named them
with a number.
The idea here is to take the work on its
own terms.
Movies and books don't have that option,
but when woody allen uses the same font
and title sequence for every single
movie he's ever done,
the point I think is to look beyond the
titles to the film itself,
but even that nondecision is a kind of
decision.
I mean,
the title isn't the most important thing
about a movie,
but attention to detail is something
that I appreciate as a film goer.
I mean,
if you're going to spend all that time
and all that money making a feature
film,
why not try to make everything in and
around it?
Meaning,
forget it.
I can't go in two minutes.
Sorry.
I can't do it.
We've blown it already.
I,
you know,
I can't go into,
in a minute in the Middle East,
the titles there in Swedish,
there is a nerd writer video every
Wednesday.
So if you click that box right there,
you'll subscribe to this channel and get
all the videos.
My girlfriend is just scared the shit
out of me.
I have to think squarespace for
sponsoring this video.
They make sleek,
intuitive websites.
I just made one called the nerd
writer.net.
You can check that out.
Um,
and if you sign up for a year and you
get a free domain name and if you use
the offer code nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
Also,
me and my girlfriend are going to be
living in Venice,
Italy for the next month,
starting Friday.
So if you live out there,
if you,
uh,
if you want to get in touch,
you can email me at [inaudible] dot
[inaudible] at Gmail and I will see you
guys next Wednesday.
The rest of you,
hopefully I see some of you in Venice.